un lundi 1er novembre au Cimetière du
Père Lafosse de Saint-Louis l'heure est
à la mémoire et à la
prière ici on parle du cimetière des
esclaves et aujourd'hui encore on
demande beaucoup au père la fosse mais
le temps n'a-t-il pas quelque peu effacé
les traces de son œuvre nos vieux
grandpère longtemps nous a toujours
parlé du père la fosse c un prêtre ici à
Saint-Louis venu de métropole dans le
temps
deesclavage ma de la commune de
Saint-Louis protège les esclave c'est
pour ça été démissionné de son poste je
croisoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde
gravé dans la mémoire beaucoup de monde
nous c'est Com Com un clé pour nous ça
il faut nous vient
là Fos est né à Paris en
1745 après des études chez les
Lazaristes il est ordonné prêtre en 1775
on l'envoie à Bourbon dans la paroisse
de Saint-Louis depuis son église de
Saint-Étienne le père lafusse nourrit
des convictions abolliitionnistes qui
vont trouver leur écho à la Révolution
il devient dès lors un sansculotte
enthousiaste partisan des amis de
l'égalité et de la liberté orateur
convaincant il devient le premier maire
de Saint-Louis en août
1790 et aux élections pour l'Assemblée
locale il décroche un siège de
députés adoré et respecté par le peuple
et les 60 esclaves qu'il dorlotte dans
sa cure le père lafusse est au contraire
détesté par les propriétaires terriens
les altercations se multiplient jusqu'à
provoquer la grande insurrection du Sud
en mars
1798 durant un mois la fausse
belleeville et leurs hommes tiennent
tête ils finiront par déposer les armes
14 insurgés dont le père la fusse sont
condamnés à l'exil aux Indes le père
lafusse lui s'arrêtera au séchelle où il
séjournera quelques mois avant de
rentrer en
France en 182 le voilà deetour dans
l'île où il retrouve sa cure à
Saint-Louis il est toujours du côté des
noirs on dit qu'il aurait été assassiné
non loin de l'usine du Gaul en 187 et
que les esclaves l'uraient enterré dans
le cimetière
abandonné par la suite un pèlerinage sur
sa tombe est spontanément devenu une
manifestation populaire